all right
could AI bakes it's existential mistakes
on Monday morning a picture of an
explosion near the Pentagon spread like
photos of me flexing my quads take a
look
yeah
those are my quads
anyway the explosion was totally faked
created using artificial intelligence
that's right it was about as genuine as
cat's hair
and marriage it's true
several news agencies picked it up
including India's Republic TV and
Russian State media Outlet Russia today
both agencies that boast higher ratings
than CNN
Pony photo dropped just after U.S stock
markets opened at 9 30 in the morning
causing the S P 500 to drop 30 points
within minutes the Arlington fire
department and the Department of Defense
had to put out a joint statement
reassuring that all the bombings were a
hoax so does the rise of AI or
artificial intelligence mean mankind is
screwed
oh wow hahaha
on the other hand it certainly has to be
better than no intelligence at all
I think it could trick us into thinking
we could get attacked and when we strike
back then we unleash a real war you know
think about it a lot of people thought
the Pentagon had been bombed and that
fake news story went around the world in
the time it took me to finish this
sentence and that's because a lot of
journalists were more concerned with
being first than being correct
now we don't want to contribute to the
hysteria but we have unconfirmed reports
actually of some new bombings
[Music]
it's easy all you have to do is to
Viagra and sure make me self-conscious
about taking baths in the forest
yeah well he's used to bombing on stage
but such explosions maybe they aren't
all bad
Jesus
he took his favorite seat at lunch or
something yes can't say I disagree with
that
all right uh Joe uh have you ever
considered using AI to create a full
audience at one of your shows
I I don't know why people who fell for
this that yeah exactly I mean that
picture looks like it's from a screen
grab from Call of Duty from like 2003
and people oh we can't trust Russia
Today yeah oh where am I getting my
morning horoscope from now uh Russia
Today I guess the Eight dollar Twitter
verification is not as thorough as we
thought it was going to be that Russia
Today would publish this I I think we
blame too many things on AI now right
not a it's like it's like getting fat
and blaming the vending machine yes it's
it's the person's intent you know and
it's the problem is not AI it's that
people want to believe in dumb things
that reinforce whatever they want to
believe in the first place so if you
want to believe the Pentagon had been
attacked
then you would believe that photo if you
didn't you would look at it and you know
it was phony and the problem is it's
human nature it's like Dr zayas said 98
he said man is the devil's uh tool and
he was a doctor he was a doctor as was
Dr Jill
a full-blown doctor cat if you could
manipulate AI to fool people into
believing something have you ever
thought about what that something could
be like if like not like blowing at the
Pentagon but maybe something else like
uh I don't know
no I just don't think I have like it in
me to keep up a delusion no no yeah I
think also people are kind of a little
bit overreacting to this what happened
to him out there did you stroke out yes
who is that guy
[Laughter]
don't worry I don't care I don't care
um
okay I
I everyone's like we need massive
Federal Regulation of AI people were
confused for several minutes
okay I don't think I know that everybody
loves the government more than I do but
please don't be that big of a like
you don't need to call the government
and you just Google it and like No No
One's Gonna Start A War I know we don't
have con you know Congress declare war
anymore even though we're supposed to
according to the Constitution I think it
takes a few more than a few minutes for
people to decide that I think at least
you Google first is it I think it's
amazing too that if this stuff actually
worked how come Ukraine or Russia
haven't used it like that they would
have every reason to use Ai and they're
not doing it instead they use other
propaganda that we see through uh Tyrus
is this why we can't trust that we can't
trust anything now unless we see it with
our own eyes well we can't trust
ourselves and that's what this is AI is
now an excuse for I think Joe made a
great point to where like if you're a
bad actor it's not an individual person
some jackass one on Twitter and put fake
bombs around the Pentagon now it's AI
yeah there's like a new word for racist
it's AI is AI is AI no it's people on
keyboards doing dumb and then of course
everyone jumps to it and retweets
because we're all talking about it and
it's no different than every time you do
the videos with all of a sudden you have
quads the size of Godzilla and stuff
like that that's not AI That's real
that's his buddy Gene doing cut and
paste on the computer for 47 hours
okay so let's if it was AI that had been
an actual explosion okay so let's stop
using the term AI like it's it's a
clever thing no it wasn't it was not an
AI it was an AJ it was ah it's a good
point it probably wasn't AI at all it
was just somebody doing some stupid crap
yeah yes okay then that leads me to the
important business question to the
business person here yes no not you
referring to the the young lady in the
audience wearing a business school
person incorrected no Okay so it caused
a tiny movement in the stock market
right but it was still a lot of money it
was 100 billion dollars so in the matter
of of minutes whether it was an AI or a
stupid person or whoever it was it
wasn't enough for the markets the S P
500 sold off over one third of one
percent that's a hundred billion dollars
in stock valuations just gone because of
a fake picture so regardless of who
created it I think it just speaks to the
fragility and maybe the how easy you can
manipulate the world's largest stock
market I mean it did it quickly
recovered
um but this is a major problem Elon Musk
who created open source AI has said you
know the zombie apocalypse is coming of
the computers like Will Smith and iRobot
he said hey there needs to be some type
of Regulation even if you're a
Libertarian or in favor of small
government the problem is Congress
doesn't know how to regulate this kind
of stuff they don't even know what AI
saying are you saying that maybe you and
I should get together and come up with
something like think about this you're
selling you you buy a bunches
you think you should you put out the you
put out the you show like something blow
up the stock goes down then you buy it
yeah you can do that and you will be in
jail
my stocks took a hit my new company
Pentagon brand bomb repellent we got
whale about it
I don't know I think I'm gonna be a
stock guy yeah because I would Google it
yes
that is true or if you're at the
Pentagon step outside yeah nope nope
having a report all right we got to move
on hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else